everything you've learned you're just
all ready to tackle your first
programming assignment before you do
that let me just give you a quick tour
of I Tyson notebooks in Coursera
here's the jupiter ipython notebook that
you can get to on Coursera let me just
quickly show you a few features of this
the instructions are rented right here
in the text in the ipython notebook and
these long real light grey blocks are
lots of code so occasionally you see in
these blocks sometimes looks like
business a star code here in encode here
to do their prime exercise please make
sure to write your code between the star
code here and in code here so for
example print hello world's greatest and
then execute a code block you can hit
shift enter and then to execute this
code block which I guess we just wrote
print hello world so that printed hello
world to run a cell you can also run one
of these code blocks in the cells can
also click cell and then run cell so
they execute this it's possible that on
your computer the keyboard shortcut for
a silver answer might be different than
shift-enter but on both my math as well
as on my PC is shift-enter so might be
the same for you as well
now when you're reading the instructions
if you you know accidentally
double-click on it you might end up with
this markdown language if you end up
with this funny-looking text to convert
it back to the nice-looking test just
run this cell so you either go to cell
run cell or I'm going to hit shift enter
and that basically excuse the markdown
and turns it back into this nice-looking
code just a couple more tips when you
execute code like this it actually runs
on a kernel unknown on on a piece of
code that runs on the server um if if
you're running an excessively large job
or if you're a Geneva computer for a
very long time well something goes wrong
your internet connection or something
there is a small chance that the kernel
on the back end might die every stage
just click kernel and then restart
kernel and hopefully that will reboot
the kernel and we can work it in so that
shouldn't happen if you're just running
so these small jobs and you just started
up the iPad 2 notebook but if if you see
an error message then the kernel has
died or something you can try Colonel
Reese dot finally in an AI Titan
notebook like this there may be multiple
blocks of code so even if an earlier
block of code doesn't it doesn't have
any critical they're sure to execute
this block of code because in this
example it imports numpy as NP and so on
and sets us on the variables that you
might need in order to execute the lower
down blocks of code so be sure to
execute the ones on top even if you
aren't asked to write any code Pingdom
and finally when you're done
implementing a solution does this move
submit assignment button G on the upper
right and we click that to all submit
your solutions for grading I found that
the interactive command shell nature of
ipython notebook to be very useful for
let me quickly implement if you like to
go see an outcome learn and is very
quickly and so I hope that the program
exercises in Coursera Jupiter ipython
notebook will help you quickly learn an
experiment and see how to implement
these learning algorithms there's one
more video after this is an optional
video that talks about the cost function
for logistic regression now you can
watch that or not either way is
perfectly fine but either way best of
luck with the week 2 programming
assignment and I also referred to seeing
you at the start of the weekly materials